y si me van a matar mátenme pero les
digo de frente no me van a silenciar
Bienvenidos a la plataforma digitales de
Rafael Moreno era un periodista que se
cruzaba todas las líneas sin ningún tipo
de temor y denunciaba absolutamente a
todos los actores que él consideraba
estaban involucrados en temas de
corrupción se robaron mil millones de
pesos en 50 días a Rafael Moreno Rafael
Moreno Rafael Moreno garavito hombres
armados le dispararon cuando se
encontraba en un local de venta de
comida
Un minuto de silencio de pie por el
asesinato Cobarde del periodista Rafael
Emilio moreno garavito Me callaron la
boca para que no seguía no siguiera
denunciando toda la podrida corrupción
que hay en Colombia
Buenos días Rafael
en el papel me mandan esto
[Música]
absolute